breaking tonight finally a bombshell new
development in the durham probe one of
christopher steele's primary sources
in this case a russian analyst has now
been indicted coming up we're going to
tell you what this could mean for
hillary clinton comey's doj and other
high-level actors that pushed the russia
collusion lie in hoax for what five
years now now indications are beginning
to mount tonight that durham may have
figured this all out a little late but
who should be worried tonight also we
begin tonight democrats around the
country they are still reeling from this
major election loss on tuesday in
virginia new jersey around the country
by the way even in new jersey the
republican candidate jack citarelli is
within two points of the democratic
incumbent governor no one has conceded
to this point and now democratic
infighting it is boiling over democratic
denial is even worse and joe biden's
build back better new green deal
socialist spending spree all that is in
jeopardy tonight one senior democratic
aide telling chad pergram
uh capitol hill has now descended into a
total
adam schiff show and humiliated from
this week's losses some democrats some
media mobsters they are blaming racist
americans who love white supremacy well
that's a little hard to explain
considering some of the wins that took
place tuesday all while ignoring the
historic election of for example winsome
sears who was on the show last night and
others like congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez they are blaming members
of their own party why because they're
not radical enough
great strategy take a look
i know that virginia was a huge bummer
and honestly if anything
i think that the results show
the limits of trying to run a fully 100
percent super moderated campaign that
does not
excite
speak to or energize a progressive base
and frankly we weren't even really
invited
to contribute on that race
that's it we're not socialist enough
climate change ranked at the bottom of
the issues for example voters in
virginia cared about the economy
education taxes they were at the top of
the list but i guess for someone that
thinks the world is going to end in 10
years logic is not necessarily a top
priority now still pelosi schumer biden
they're getting bullied by aoc and the
squad they were right back pushing their
radical agenda today doubling tripling
down on their build back better
socialist spending orgy and according to
wharton business school the true cost of
buildback better socialism is actually
over four trillion dollars by the way
credit to joe manchin who's been saying
get rid of all the accounting gimmicks
and give us real numbers so we can vote
on an honest bill that's not likely to
happen and it only raises spending 4
trillion raises 1.5 trillion in revenue
in other words that'll be three trillion
dollars that would be printed or just
added to the debt and inflation of
course will continue to skyrocket on top
of the historic levels of inflation all
of us are now
experiencing and suffering through don't
forget also record high energy prices
and pretty much everything you buy at
every store you go to is much higher and
by the way the plan calls for 185 times
more spending on climate than on future
pandemic preparedness does that make
sense now senator joe manchin does not
appear to be on board he called the
virginia results a quote wake-up call
he's right and today mansion tells fake
news cnn that america is not a
center-left country but a center-right
country and congress better take note
take a look
we just have to work together we can't
go too far left this is not a center
left or a left country
we are a center if anything has a little
center-right country and this means
that's being shown and we ought to be
able to recognize that and all of my
friends on the left are progressives or
liberals whatever i said i'm not
well apparently he along with kristin
cinema about the only two in the senate
that recognized the obvious over in the
house one virginia democrat got to give
credit now seeing the handwriting on the
wall she reportedly blasted her
colleagues for ignoring real problems
you know like the real inflation the
high cost of energy the supply chain
issues trashing bill back better saying
quote nobody elected joe biden to be fdr
and meanwhile democratic strategist guy
i have debated many times actually like
him he's smart as hell he's certainly a
dinosaur in terms of his way of thinking
which is far more center left uh but at
least partly center james carville
believes his own party has completely
lost its way and he's correct take a
look
what went wrong
but wrong was just stupid wokeness all
right don't just look at virginia and
new jersey look at long island look at
buffalo look at minneapolis even look at
seattle washington i mean just defund
the police
lunacy just take abraham lincoln's name
off of schools i mean that
people see that
and it it it it's just really have a
suppressive effect all across the
country the democrats some of these
people that need to go to a woke detox
center or something
it's taken 30 years i think it finally
won james over his word stupid wokeness
carl's right the radical socialists woke
base of that party they rule the party
they're not going anywhere in fact they
now rule the entire democratic party and
they do so with an iron fist now biden's
woke doj led by the far left merrick
garland they're planning on issuing
six-figure payments to certain illegal
immigrants now yesterday a very
bewildered and perplexed and befuddled
joe biden denied that any such plan was
in the works as it turns out joe just
wasn't in the loop as usual today his
deputy press secretary said yeah biden
does actually support these payments in
other words let me translate our own
peter ducey was correct again take a
look
the president is perfectly comfortable
with the department of justice settling
with the individuals and families who
are currently in litigation with the u.s
government you know doj can obviously
speak more to that process
now while you struggle with rising gas
prices rising food prices rising housing
costs rising transportation costs the
biden administration is cutting huge
checks 450 000 to illegal immigrants
they will be getting hundreds of
thousands of dollars each out of your
pocket people that did not respect our
laws did not respect our borders or our
sovereignty and entered this country
illegally that would be called madness
that would be called insanity now
welcome to america
last policies forget about america first
this is america dead last america the
sucker nation that allows china and
india to be classified as developing
nations and we bear the brunt of paying
everything for the paris climate accords
and when you think it can't get any
worse now china they're actually mocking
joe biden for being powerless after his
groveling apology at the world climate
summit it's pathetic now joe falls
asleep has to be woken up by an aide he
apologizes just like his idol barack
obama for america he has no clue earthly
clue at all that his own state
department has a policy and is planning
on paying illegal immigrants 450 000
each and even after being denied
repeatedly he goes back again to beg
opec and russia to produce more oil i
keep telling you joe all you have to do
is ask texas alaska north dakota
oklahoma they'll be more than happy to
accommodate but the bottom line is
democrats who are they hurting the poor
the middle class oh i thought nobody was
going to pay a penny more if they made
uh under 400 000 a year nope the people
bearing the brunt of these horrific
policies are the poor and the middle
class that democrats claim they have a
monopoly of compassion on for them by
the way virtue signaling and political
power well are the only things that
matter